[Music]
will president biden sign the
bipartisan deal if it's not tied
to a reconciliation package later
the president has been unequivocal about
the following point
which answers your question he intends
to sign
both of those bills
which is not unequivocal nor an answer
to my question we're back with the panel
um
trey the reason there was a statement
put out saturday is because it was
confusing on friday
whether he would sign one without the
second one
i think confusing is being generous uh
brett
but look i mean progressives are sitting
there looking at roads and bridges and
airports and saying we could have gotten
out with trump
i mean we didn't elect you to give us
what we could have gotten with president
trump
they want the the aoc bernie sanders
stuff
and they haven't been to west virginia
so they don't realize that biden
actually didn't carry a single solitary
county in west virginia
and joe manchin ain't voting for all
that so look
welcome to what the tea party and the
freedom caucus
you know welcome to that on the left
that's the fight they're having right
now speaking of which congresswoman
alexander ocasio-cortez here you go
for me it's not as much about a price
tag although i do think that there is
a level where we do go too small but i
think it's really about
what impact are we making we really need
to understand that this is our one
big shot not just in terms of family
child care medicare
but on climate change so one is is the
president trying to tip to tiptoe
through the tulips here
not anger the progressives but get a
deal
but maybe not get the other deal is that
possible
yeah i think this is a high wire act
because
you know look at we live in polarized
political times this is a rare
bipartisan deal real compromise
and uh you just have to say you know
biden
had a slip there he almost slipped off
the wire he was right to
correct himself uh even seem very
apologetic
so that's what's gonna it's gonna take
it's gonna be necessary for them but
right now you have
more paths to failure than success brett
you know you stop and think about it
mitch mcconnell the republican leader in
the senate he doesn't want to give
a democratic president a win in his
first two years and then you have
the bernie sanders alexandria
ocasio-cortez wing
who think that you've got to throw
everything in there and let's just push
it through
i don't think that's going to happen it
may not happen
but right now you have this bipartisan
deal
up on the wire everyone pushing against
it
but it's a real deal and you know i
never thought it'd get this far
you know it's interesting mansion always
comes up the democratic senator from
west virginia but there's kirsten cinema
there's
uh warner from virginia there's maggie
hassan from new hampshire there's jackie
rosen from nevada
there's a lot of different senators
who've expressed concerns
over different elements of this byron
you know representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez who we just heard from
also said in addition to a bridge you
also need a babysitter
which is the best illustration of the
differences between republicans and
democrats and how they define
infrastructure that's the key conflict
here i think president biden just said
the quiet part
out loud the plan was to have him be mr
bipartisan
while nancy pelosi plays tough partisan
hardball certainly she does that i mean
after all she held up
a coveted relief bill for months last
year at the worst part of the pandemic
she would certainly
be happy to hold up this bipartisan bill
in order to get
the so-called human infrastructure bill
that democrats want
i don't think it's been any secret what
schumer and pelosi are planning
but biden just said the quiet part out
loud we're
condensing panels because of the
breaking news but talking about
crime spike homicides in major cities
new york up 12 percent oakland 82
portland 533 percent other crime
increases major cities
hate crimes carjackings rape auto theft
arson
this is real it's not uh hype terrain
crime prevention public safety is
preeminent function of government so if
you want to see government
failing at a galactic level look at our
crime rate
juan last word well i think crime is
rising in terms of murders but we have
to be very careful here that's the one
area and it's related to the guns that's
why in the latest fox pole you get
57 percent of americans think the easy
access to guns is a threat to the
stability the whole country
but it's not a crime wave in that way
it's a murder wave
byron i'll give you the last word
there's a lot of concern about police
departments and where that stands
every time there's a crime wave people
talk about one thing
increasing police departments democrats
need to talk about
that more there was a washington post
story that said democrats are starting
to talk about this
and then it quoted one who said
democrats need to be open
but they talked to not anonymously
wouldn't say who they were
we'll follow that hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else